The seventh is one of the most famous women who has ever lived.
Her story has inspired poets,
dramatists,
and artists for more than 2000 years through cunning and guile.
She survived to rule Egypt as all of us siblings perished by the wayside.
I think beauty and charm led to one of the most celebrated romances in history
and the ancient world's ultimate tragedy.
In this week's biographics,
we get up close and personal with the original Queen of denial,
Cleopatra,
why the time of the birth of Cleopatra,
the seventh and 69 bce.
Egypt had a 3000 year old history of power and decline.
The country was ruled by a dynasty of Pharaoh's each with a named ptolemy who
had arrived from Macedonia in 323 bce.
Now,
however they face the danger of invasion from the menacing Roman empire.
First ptolemies had ruled benevolently,
but their descendants,
including Cleopatra's father proved to be weak,
even foolish leaders as a results Cleopatra's early years were unsettled.
She knew that her family was at war with the people that it rules and with
itself,
the people suffered under the cruelty of Ptolemy.
The Twelfth Cleopatra's father,
and they resented his alliance with Rome when Cleopatra was just four years old,
the citizens of Alexandria rioted and Chase Ptolemy out of Egypt.
He fled to Romance Cleopatra's oldest sister Berenice became queen.
Three years later,
ptolemy returns to Egypt with the help of Roman General Pompei.
He snatched back power from baroness and ruled again as Pharaoh.
One of his first orders was for his oldest daughter to be executed.
Cleopatra now had two surviving sisters and two younger brothers.
All of ptolemies children hoped to eventually ruled,
which made them all rivals shortly after the execution of baroness,
the oldest daughter of Ptolemy,
Cleopatra.
Trifacta died in mysterious circumstances.
Many historians believe that she was poisoned by one of her siblings.
Now,
Cleopatra had only one sister still alive,
the youngest Asano.
She must've wondered how long she would survive.
Her.
Two younger brothers were named Ptolemy.
According to the custom,
they would both eventually become rulers of Egypt as Ptolemy,
the 13th and Ptolemy the 14th.
By the time she was 14.
Cleopatra was ptolemies oldest living daughter.
When he died,
she would become queen as the wife of her younger brother Ptolemy the 13th for
the young girl.
The prospect filter with both excitement and terror,
vividly recalling the fate of her two sisters,
she fed the enemies,
might also tried to kill her,
but the young girl was clever.
She had made friends with powerful courtiers who she felt would protect her.
Cleopatra was groomed for rulership from her early teens.
She learns new languages,
including Egyptian,
which surprisingly was not spoken at all in the royal court.
All her family members,
they simply spoke Greek.
She also used religion to support our claim to the throne,
claiming to be the daughter of the sun gods,
ancient royal title.
When their father died,
Cleopatra and her husband slash brother began their rule.
It was 51 BC and she was nearly 18 years of age,
10 years older than the new king.
This allowed her to assume full responsibility for ruling the country.
It was a particularly complex time.
In addition to domestic problems which included a discontented peasantry brought
to its knees by famine.
Not to mention the hostility of other members of our own family.
There were also problematic foreign relations.
The most pressing issue was the unrelenting demands for taxes coming from Rome.
Despite the requirements of having a husband Ptolemy,
the 13th appointed to rule with her.
She didn't take kindly to having him tagging along.
Her solution was to oust him from his position and rule alone for the next 18
months.
One thing that we knew for sure was that she could not beat the Romans that
their military game at this point,
so therefore she had to take off where I left off and keep appeasing the Roman
overlords.
She attempted damage control by working with the Roman oppressors in the hope
that they would give up on Egypt entirely like a father.
She chose survival,
but she had one advantage over him.
Cleopatra,
she was clever and she knew how to play the cards that she was dealt to best
advantage.
She would continue to do so throughout her reign.
Up until the very end,
she wasn't allowed to fold her hands if she could see any way to play to the
best of her ability.
And she would absolutely bluff if necessary.
She would eliminate every other folk in the game and keep a few aces up our
sleeve by willing key Alexandrians Romans and the priests over to our site.
She was a brilliant strategist even at the young age when she became regions.
However,
given that she was ruling Egypt and given the tempestuous history of our family,
nothing was going to come easy to a new ruler,
especially a female one.
Her little brother had his supporters or should I say his controllers,
and they wanted to have the power in their hands,
not in the hands of Cleopatra.
When I say they,
I'm speaking mainly of a man named goodness Pompei,
who at the time was the supreme control river.
Him The man who gave her father the title of King and the person who was given
the rights to possess Cypress.
It is highly unlikely that Pompei saw Cleopatra as too smart to simply be
mollified as her father had been.
She would be hard to control and a constant threat to Roman dominance over
Egypt.
How there's a brother needed some assistance and this was given to him in the
form of room and support.
Pompei would show up occasionally to formally recognize the little brother over
the big sister as the ruler of Egypt with pompey is backing Ptolemy,
the 13th when to war with his big sister driving half from power in 49 ce,
Cleopatra discovered that her husband was plotting with palm pay to send
soldiers to kidnap and possibly kill her.
She knew that she must leave Egypt's and so she said,
sail for Syria.
Eventually hope to recruit an army to help our wind back the throne from her.
Now.
Sixteen year old husband slash brother Cleopatra choose to flee to Syria because
the ptolemies had once ruled that the king of Syria was also an enemy of Rome.
Like Cleopatra.
He fears that his own country would be taken over by the mighty Roman Empire.
She took her only surviving sister I'll send into exile without.
This was partly to protect the younger girl from her brother's raft,
but also to stop her from seizing the throne herself.
While these dramas were playing out in the ptolemaic dynasty up north,
a bloody civil war was taking place General Julius Caesar Battles and defeated
the forces of general pompey.
Pompey arrived in Glucagon in Egypt's hoping to get money,
food,
men and ships because he was running low on what he needed to defeat Caesar.
Up until that time,
the Egyptians had been on the receiving ends of much of the support from room
due to the relationship established between Cleopatra's father and Pompei.
Before Caesar rose up to challenge the Redmond general and now the pump.
They had just lost badly to seize a fossil.
This he needed Egypt's help.
Meanwhile sees it was in pursuits and also looking for aid for his military
needs.
He arrived in Alexandria with a rather modest military force.
However,
it seems to the young Egyptian king and his advisors that Cesar was going to be
the eventual victor in Rome.
If the king continue to support Pompei to continue his war against Caesar on
Egyptian soil,
the battles could devastate Egypt's and if pompei eventually last season would
be enraged against the Egyptian readership.
Caught between a rock and a hard place.
As soon as Pompei landed with troops that palace,
Iom,
Ptolemy,
the 13th,
had Pompei,
ambushed and killed event delivered pompous had to Desisa.
However,
the king miscalculated.
How happy sees would be to see as enemies had presented to him by the Egyptian
king.
Pompei may have been his rival,
but it was up to Caesar to decide Pompez face not have the upstart Egyptian
king.
You said that right.
Even though he was horrified by the brutal murder of Pompei,
Caesar wanted to keep the peace he had come to Egypt to collect a huge sum of
money that you've claimed Cleopatra's father had owed him.
He ordered both Ptolemy and Cleopatra to meet with him to discuss the P
streeting.
The now 21 year old queen saw her opportunity to act.
She slipped past ptolemies general,
the killers.
It was blocking Glucagon and sales along the coastline to Alexandria bike,
way of denial.
Then she went to see Caesar at the palace.
Cleopatra had developed into a very mature and savvy young women.
Legend has it that she secret at a self in a rolled up bedroll in order to get
into the palace that this has largely been debunked,
but she did not need to go through quite so covert length to get an audience
with Cesar in Alexandria.
She had been communicating with him from her posts over the border shortly
before sneaking past to kill us and heading toward Alexandria.
She sent word to Caesar that she was coming or he had sent word to her,
telling her to come.
Either way,
it's likely it was no surprise that Cleopatra was arriving in the harbor that
night.
Apparently Cleopatra,
dawn's her most impressive outfits and took great effort to look beautiful for
her audience with season whatever she did,
worked a treat and sees the ordered that she'd be restored to the throne.
Naturally.
When Ptolemy arrived to find Cleopatra and the palace re-installed as CCO
regions,
he was not at all pleased.
In fact,
he threw a royal fit as impressed as Caesar was with the Queen.
He wisely took into consideration the support that her brother,
Hans,
among many of the upper crust of Alexandria.
Therefore,
he decided to handle the situation astutely,
he wisely reds to brother and sister,
the will of the father,
which stated that he wanted them to rule together,
but the young king,
he was not appeased.
He ran out of the palace and threw down his crown in a terrible rage and a new
season.
Allow Ptolemy to leave the city and join his sister,
Austin.
No.
In Sicily days after the Alexandrian war ended,
the advocated king's body was found lying in the harbor
for the first time in years.
Cleopatra now felt safe,
uh,
enemy husbands,
along with his advisors were dead and Caesar had promised to protect her and her
new husband,
her surviving 11 year olds,
brother Ptolemy,
the 14th with Caesar.
She sailed down the Nile in order to be test subjects and impress them with our
power.
Rumor spread that she was pregnant with seizes child,
which came to be known as ces,
Arion.
When he's at return to Rome,
he left at 15,000 of his finest soldiers to guard the queen after taking control
of Egypt.
Return to Rome where he was hailed as a hero before long.
Cleopatra had come north to join him.
She claimed that the trip was to negotiate a peace treaty between Egypt and
Rome,
but she also wanted to make sure of Caesar's protection.
She did not once want a younger brother or his advises to try to seize power in
Egypt while she was away.
Many Romans chief,
the relationship between Cleopatra and Caesar.
It was widely feared that Caesar would names dot Darian as his app and so the
Cleopatra would then have a hold on the Roman empire through his son sees a
celebrated his victories by parading his captives through the streets of Rome.
Cleopatra sister also know who led the Egyptian army against Caesar,
was dragged through the streets,
back headed in chains.
It was a disgrace for women to appear in public this way.
At the time it was the custom for Egyptian women to wear a long cloak and avail
outside of their homes.
However,
Austin,
I was lucky,
unlike other prisoners,
she was not killed.
Caesar felt that the Romans might right if they saw a princess publicly executed
to give.
Thanks for the victory at the battle of soulless sees that builds a new
template,
Rome.
He also paid for a beautiful statue of Cleopatra to be put on display in the
temple.
It showed her as a mother holding and in her arms
as a
reward for his victories.
The Senate made sees a dictator for life,
but some Romans feared that Caesar was becoming too powerful and that he wanted
to be king.
About 60 conspirators decided that Caesar had to be killed.
The plants which was led by brutus and Cassius was carried through immediately
following a Senate meeting in 44 BC,
the shocking news of Caesar's murder spread through the Roman empire like
wildfire.
Cleopatra who was in Rome at the time of the assassination lost no time in
hurrying back to Egypt now that season protect who was dead.
A kingdom was once more in danger.
Many hostile nations saw Egypt as a rich prize and hope to conquer it.
Cleopatra kept us sciences area enclosed by her side because she feared that he
might be murdered by his enemies on her return to Egypt.
Cleopatra found this sister.
I'll ask to know who had been released from Raymond Captivity,
was plotting with an anti seize a faction in the hype of seizing power.
Many of the nobles in the Egyptian court supported arsenault and joined her in
her conspiracy against Cleopatra.
At this time that nation was suffering a crisis due to the failure of the Nile
floods.
There was not enough water in the river to spread rich mode over the fields in
order to irrigate them.
As a result,
farmers' crops and animals died,
and as many families suffered from famine and disease,
many nobles and officials were angry that Cleopatra did not take moves to help
the victims of the famine.
The tenuous situation for Cleopatra Mandatory needed a new Rehmann protector who
she could lean on,
and that came in the form of Marc Antony.
CAESARS murder led to three terrible years of warfare in Rome as different
groups of Roman senators and members of leading Roman families struggled to take
control.
The rival armies were led by three powerful men and each hopes to take seizes
places.
Ruler,
their names were octavian who sees his nephew,
Mark Antony and Marcus.
Let us finally in 42 bce,
the room and lands were divided among the three Manzanita control of the entire
eastern Mediterranean region,
which included Egypt's
and control of Egypt,
Tanzania.
It's still needed Cleopatra's support,
and he feared that she might support his enemies.
He needed goals from Egypt in order to pay his armies in order to keep control
of his share of the empire.
He also needed Egypt screen in order to feed his men Anthony rates of Cleopatra
runs when she did not reply,
he summoned to meet him.
Cleopatra was in no hurry to response Anthony.
Instead.
She deliberately took her time.
She knew that anthony needed Egypt skulls and in return she planned to ask for
his protection.
She also wanted his help to kill enemies,
including her sister,
Austin.
I as neat waited for Cleopatra to arrive to the plans meeting and tacitus.
He heard news of large crowds gathering to witness an amazing site.
Cleopatra was sailing up the riverside nus in a barge.
It's sales popple.
It's is urging is end with silver rose to the sound of the flute,
blended with pipes and loot.
The sales were made of silk,
irr and costly cough from China.
It was a floating palace.
The queen herself was dressed as the Greek goddess of Love Aphrodite.
She laid on my couch beneath the canopy of gold cloth.
Marc Antony was mesmerized and he invited Cleopatra Design with them,
but the queen refused insisting that he joined her on her royal barge.
She did a great cat without preparations.
She wants it to Anthony to be delighted,
astonished,
and most importantly impressed.
She arranged for her to be decorated with thousands of tiny oil lamps and
glittering flickering patterns of lights,
Cleopatra,
Metadata to it several times during her visits to toss this on each occasion,
she dressed as the goddess Aphrodite.
She offered ends and the crowns of vine leaves say symbol of diagnosis,
the Greek God of wine.
She was reminding Antony that according to legend task,
this was the place where aphrodite and diagnosis met and fell in love.
Cleopatra's seduction worked how dramatic visit to Tarsus had one.
Anthony support in her struggled to remain the ruler of Egypt as he forgot his
war against the Parthians and hurried to Egypt.
They spends the winter of 41 bce and Alexandria together during which time
Cleopatra on the left hand side.
During this time,
her two remaining siblings,
arsenault and Ptolemy,
14th,
were put to death.
Shortly thereafter,
Cleopatra became pregnant.
Anthony did not remain in Europe to see the birth of his twins,
a boy and a girl in 40 BC had to return to Rome because his wife fava was
leading a rebellion against Octavian.
Cleopatra continued to really Jeb.
It's because Anthony did not return for another four years when he sailed back
in 36 BC after a disastrous defeat and Patho,
Cleopatra welcomes him.
She needed a strong ally to help keep Egypt independence.
Anthony plans to set up an empire in North Africa and the Middle East to
challenges rivals in Rome.
Cleopatra supported his plans because they would increase her own power in 35
BC.
The Pat had a third child,
a son.
They named Ptolemy.
Philadelphus early in 34,
[inaudible] invaded Armenia returning to Alexandria and triumph in a magnificent
celebration.
Cleopatra was crowned Queen of the Kings.
The couples,
young children were given royal titles over Middle East Atlanta
topper,
and then politicians lead,
bike sees his nephew,
Octavian were shocked by reports of Antony and Cleopatra Space to set up an
empire on their writing.
They will also angry this anthony had divorced his Roman wife and outraged
Octavian personally declared war against Cleopatra and all of Egypt.
Even though Anthony had tried to avoid conflict with Rome,
it had now become impossible to avoid.
This was especially so after the Roman Senate.
It's found out about his will in which he declared his intention to be buried in
Egypt's beside cleopatra.
Anthony was dismissed from all public appointments even though the army
assembled by Antony and Cleopatra was large at the famous battle of actium in
September of 31 bce constituted a first fundamental step toward their defeat.
By now,
they were considered foreigners and enemies of Rome.
Anthony succeeded in taking police iom and it's getting close to the gates of
Alexandria in the spring of 30 bce and mad well of events followed,
reminded the Cleopatra and shot in the mausoleum that she had built for herself
was debt.
On hearing this news,
which was denied immediately after that too late and the wounded himself
fatally,
and as he was dying,
he was taken to the mausoleum,
Cleopatra,
wept for Antony,
and tried in various ways to take her own life that she was watched over by
Octavian is men who wanted to take it back to Rome a few days before her
departure,
however,
Cleopatra and managed to evade surveillance and kills herself probably would
snake poison which was brought into the prison in a basket.
Cleopatra was the last independent ruler of Egypt.
Death marked the end of over 3000 Gloria years of Egyptian civilization and
Egyptian power.
Yes,
she could not bear to live.
While foreign is ruled a beloved country with her death,
Egypt lost its most famous and possibly its greatest ever queen.
So I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button.
Doesn't do what it used to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday won't put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
stuff from the archive over there on the race,
and as always,
thank you for watching.